[Music]
it's been a long fight but they say it's
worth it the new york post profiling
five
canceled professors and their fight back
including this one who quit his job over
the far left agenda on campus
all the seriousness in traditional
academic institutions is and and
i i think it's really important to call
things what it is it's not the liberals
who have taken over the institutions
it's the authoritarians who have taken
over the institutions traditional
academic institutions and it's needed
because our institutions now have been
hijacked by maniacs
it's a topic our next guest knows all
too well piers morgan host of piers
morgan uncensored on fox nation and he
joins us now good morning to you pierce
good morning good morning i know that
you were tweeting about this very issue
tell us tell us why why you wanted to
focus on this
well i tell you why because actually at
the core of this is what my new show is
about piers morgan uncensored because
what is going on on college campuses not
just in america but around the world
is brutal censorship of any views by
anyone that differs from this woke you
know cancel culture mob mentality and
when you read this new york post story
it's really quite it's quite terrifying
in a way what you discover is that
nearly 600 educators at faculties
all around america have been punished in
some form for expressing opinions and
the rate of these punishments being
handed out is now multiplying four or
fivefold every year which means that
there's a real ongoing attempt to
suppress freedom of speech on college
campuses when you look through some of
these stories some of these professors
stories and thank god they're speaking
out and taking the battle to the mob
one of them actually got cancelled
because he was holding a class
educating people about how to deal with
offensive language
and as part of the lecture he used
defensive language to illustrate what he
was talking about and was immediately
branded a homophobe racist and so on for
using offensive language deliberately to
make a point about offensive language
that is how ridiculous this has all got
so i applaud these professors for
speaking out but everyone who works in a
college campus around america in fact
globally they should all be looking at
this piece and asking themselves one
question what kind of kids
are you seeing coming through these
colleges if only one narrow world view
is allowed to me it's a complete
disgrace and pierce what i hear from a
lot of professors is that they're it's
the kids who are coming into the
colleges who almost demand this type of
conformity they're the ones tattling on
teachers who dare to stand up for actual
free speech or challenging conventional
dogmas
well my kids have demanded candy from me
over the years when they were younger
did i always give them candy no i didn't
because actually sometimes i would say
don't be so ridiculous you're fill up
with candy you need something a bit more
healthy for your mental state and
physical well-being and that's exactly
the same thing at these colleges i mean
it is utterly ridiculous if if genuinely
professors are now being held to ransom
by a bunch of woke indoctrinated kids
who think they can control the people
that are trying to teach them a rounded
view of life which is what the whole
point of university or college is
supposed to be and the moment that stops
the moment you have professors being
hounded out of their jobs being punished
for expressing opinion then you're going
to start creating a whole generation of
students who come out of these places
who are completely indoctrinated and not
in a way by the way which the majority
of people feel right about issues in
life but about a very small minority a
very vocal pretty ultra woke ultra left
people who have decided it is incumbent
on them to to in a fascist like way
dictate how we're all going to think
about everything it is it is a it is a
terrifying thing as i said to read this
piece and see experienced knowledgeable
professors getting hounded out of their
job for having an opinion that these
kids should be hearing and it's got to
stop right and
you know your show gives a forum to
people who have been uh cancelled and
you know you detailed the sharon osborne
story which ran in the last week or so
but congratulations because uh i think
your first week
64
million impressions or hits or viewers
or whatever and and i saw that because
the topic uh the first one was about
donald trump and donald trump was very
proud of the fact that he was the
subject and 64 million hits but then at
the end of the statement it goes
great great great ratings but he's over
you know something happened to him piers
morgan not the same guy that he used to
be even what they had to happen to him i
think you know you've got a great
interview a great interview when a a
recently departed president of the
united states issues not one not two but
three statements so far about the
interview all of them with conflicting
reports from his mind about how he
thinks it went on the one hand he
thought it was tedious on the other hand
he thought it was brilliant he thought
the ratings were fantastic but i'm
finished and over the hill and in fact
at a rally last night i think in
nebraska he announced that i'm
officially crazy uh well mr trump if
you're watching uh i'm happily uh able
to say that i think i am probably quite
quite crazy i actually think we're all a
bit nuts and that's what makes the world
go round uh but what i would say to him
if he's watching i know he loves
watching fox and friends president trump
it was a fantastic interview everyone i
know who watched it actually i thought
you came out of it really well so why
you're going completely crackers about a
30-second promo which
as i think i said to you guys before i
simply used a promo to sell the
interview to get people to watch it
worked everybody watched and on a more
serious point i think the interesting
thing about the reaction is how
you can generate such extraordinary
volume of eyeballs around the world now
from these clips from these interviews
and to be fair to donald trump he does
generate a lot of heat with this stuff
but to get 64 million different views on
different platforms social media from
the newspapers i write columns for we
gave them exclusive clips and so on it's
really fascinating to me that you can
you can create a massive massive amount
of people watching this stuff but not in
the conventional way that we did when we
were young sure absolutely and i read a
thing over the weekend when i was down
at the white house correspondents dinner
in one of the papers down in dc about
how uh tv executives kind of missed
donald trump because their ratings were
really high when he was president
everybody was tuning in and joe biden
kind of boring is what the thing said
check out piers morgan uncensored on fox
nation he's weekdays at 4 30 in the
afternoon eastern time pierce thank you
very much thank you pierce and i'm crazy
i'm crazy i tell you read all about it
apparently we all are though that's
amazing imagine the contrast cnn plus
canceled that for three weeks fox nation
helping to drive an interview that gets
64 million views well we thank you just
saying it's a good interview
to say